welcome to this video playing papal
papua purple and yellow is from Poland
right yes 2,300 rating and it's an ouzo
hmm okay let's let's play this live
check this is a funny gambit line quite
interesting the best term this is
interesting don't know that line usually
you take and after c6 why doesn't
capture k let's take at least them this
looks like very a nice development how
to play hmm
yeah probably just just here attacking
the default pawn yeah Black has a very
nice development white cannot play d5
and needs to take which is really not
what he wants yeah maybe bishops III is
this idea but I have an ID see form this
would actually be a big mistake okay so
let's see okay let's let's try for a
little trap if you place king of to iop
to King f2 is a very logical move here
connecting works you probably saw that
okay now i have c 5 so if it takes i can
take on be too i can play 9393 probably
the easiest winning the exchange and
it's a good move anyway controlling the
center bishops III that's still not see
for you know they are the only question
here really is if I should take on on be
too but I am let's grab let's grab the
exchange
yeah all my pieces are active this is so
very yeah this is very nice I have no no
passive piece really let's go here he
doesn't have a good move to protect the
b2 pond I can't move it okay but then
his King position still still is a big
issue
hmm I'm not sure how to play this many
good good options ok I go from for Queen
trade with Quincy to but i'm not sure if
i should just play on with queens and
it's tricky after the Queen trade black
asses of course better with the material
advantage but he also had a very bad
coordination which often is small
problem with Queens on
I want to at the end attack the a3 pawn
but on what I need to do is activate my
night this is not a good piece at the
moment it mostly looks at f3 and g4 and
those are obviously protected so maybe
95 b6 to see for this kind of route yeah
yeah he's preventing a d5 okay let's
check check the pawn
hmm
yeah probably we should see one I don't
think again yeah no reason not to take
it really ok d5 of course he wants to go
to d5
hmm there's some really convincing way
to answer that I can I can mix the night
but then 95 anyway
hmm yeah slightly annoying if he gets
here it's it's a bit of a problem the
knight on d5 just text f6 and it also
attacked them protected before and this
is not easy at all because of my bed
power structure
check
you five I have rugae six check check
yeah so it's a pawn but this wasn't it
wasn't correct fun anyway so let's see
this is firm obviously very difficult to
win probably impossible cam that's
really disappointing like was completely
winning really check button to force
nicely defended check check check
and this still offers some chances check
to be honest time morning most most
difficult is the time check yeah this is
no winning law I think with activity
check check no one Luke f6 this was
actually mostly by saw that no it's just
you know can I mean what do i do one of
those early games in a session where
really the brain is not working probably
it was really a mouse sleep I saw them I
saw the fork it was yeah it was it was
really a complete draw but he allowed me
to to to activate the rook end to get
rid of weaknesses can't bench at eight
it's difficult to play with the law
check check yeah it's really over just
just over the easiest is just to play
kings you for him it okay I didn't have
much time check and now I'm just I'm
just ready to pick everything up yeah I
wanted to play rook f6 and that is
really easy just just promoting
promoting the pawn um but real shame is
that he got out of this alive because
the this is just very very good for
black
let me just briefly check him in this I
think it's quite ok and here yeah ok
it's an exchange it really should should
be very good maybe I should play an
earlier night d fire here 95 this is
just stronger the c-4 move was really
good that he that he played and this is
just just excellent how does he does he
even protect stuff now only three Jesus
just this is just winning with rookie
aid coming do you five coming yeah I
should have ended this game at the right
right ear and curiously enough it wasn't
it wasn't clear-cut really here I should
probably take it and play and play
something else this is not easy here not
at all
yeah this is not it not at all easeus as
mentioned oh it's a typical case where
the computer doesn't understand the
position it's just to those people who
believe every computer eval is correct
computer says he and this case black is
completely winning which is kept
solutely nonsense white has some very
decent chances to draw here with
fortresses and fortresses computers
don't understand at all yeah bit of a
shame should have won this in the
opening already but spoiled it at the
end thanks for watching